today I have a car trick I'm going to
show you this card trick here we go just
a bunch of cards and I need someone to
pick a card
so let's randomly pick a card out of
there we go there's your card I haven't
seen it you're memorizing it and you can
stick it back in the pile here anywhere
anywhere you like
okay all right and just to be extra
careful that I didn't see anything it's
really mixed up in there there's no way
I could know it I'm going to shuffle
these cards and then now I'm going to
deal them out into three piles and for
show I need you to remember this card so
that you can mentally pass along that
information to me and we can help that
card rise to the top okay so you point
to which column you see your card I see
it this one here okay perfect
all right so we're going to divide them
up again and I hope you remembering your
cards because otherwise this trick might
not work all right and now where do you
see it yeah okay that makes me a little
nervous but that's alright alright one
more time just to be safe okay so think
hard about this card and where is it now
it is this one this one oh all right I
think that's okay all right
okay so point to four piles for me
please yeah let's go with that these
four here these four here okay great
and now how about two piles from these
ones left these two on the end the two
on the end okay
and one more the one closest ta
this one okay oh no I'm feeling nervous
okay one of these cards please
middle one middle one how did we do
did we do it
oh wait did I not make it you got it I
got it oh think I was a little nervous
[Laughter]
that was very good right I imagined the
people in the audience are probably a
little more excited right maybe I'm a
little more relieved let's break it down
so the first thing we need to know is
the name of this trick is actually the
21 card trick so the one piece of
information I kept from you is how many
cards I have so I have twenty-one cards
in my hand and so you can really start
thinking about this in terms of modular
arithmetic so I'm thinking about numbers
and when I divide that number by some
fixed number like three I can ask for
which remainder does that number have it
can have remainder zero so maybe it's
like six divided by three has no
remainder 7 has remainder 1 so 7 divided
by 3 I can get 3 times 2 is 6 plus 1 so
I can get 1 and then I can also have 2
so like 8 divided by 3 has remainder 2
okay so I can think about dividing up my
numbers any integer divided by 3 into
these 3 groups where the remainder 0
remainder 1 remainder 2 okay so we
picked and we picked a card that was the
first thing we did yeah
whatever nice time so hate this time two
of clubs okay so everybody knows and
it's okay because eventually I already
was going to know that but okay two of
clubs
so we stick it back in and just for show
I missed them up this was this is a
little cute this was a roof shot yeah
this is for sure I'm not doing anything
special here just to to add to the
enjoyment of the randomness of it all
you certainly my my dog could have
shuffled in I guess so two of clubs
that's the one we were looking for the
second step was to divide them up into
these columns so the card can definitely
be anywhere but now I'm dividing them up
into three columns if you recall we
discussed modulo arithmetic so we're
thinking about dividing up twenty-one
cards by three so one of those cards has
to be in the column where there you
could think the remainder is one the
remainder is 2 or the remainder is zero
and so we see our card here okay so the
first thing we want to do is make sure
that this column has to be sandwiched
between the two other columns and the
reason I'm going to do this is because
this one has seven cards in it I don't
know which card you know supposedly I
don't know which card it is but I know
now it's somewhere in positions so
there's seven here once I put this one
on top of these cards it's got to be
positions 8 9 10 11 12 13 or 14 so in
positions 8 through 14 lies your card
and then I'm going to add the rest of
these cards here and so that helps me
know for sure it's right in this section
8 to 14 so when I separate them up again
or divide them up into these three
columns here are the first seven those
are the ones that I stacked on top of my
group know I'm going there right here
comes eight so maybe I'll kind of go
like this so we can see 8 9 10 11 12 13
and 14 so there's that collection of
cards where your card has to live and
then I just do the rest of them here
and what happened is I took 8 through 14
I divided it up by 3 and those numbers
have to have remainder 1 2 or 0 and so
it did spread them across my columns and
now the rows that they live in has
shrunk so you can see that whatever your
whichever card we know that we need to
find has to be in row so this one goes
in here and here just to make it clear
has to live in Row 3 4 or 5 another way
you can think about it is as soon as I
do this the same thing of sticking
whichever column you say your card in
which is here after 7 cards that means
it's in position 8 9 10 11 and possibly
12 because this one had three rows
involved okay so now I'm looking at
positions 10 11 and 12
that might contain your card so now I'm
going to pick up this column where your
card lives I'm going to put it between
the two columns of seven cards and now
we were remembering positions 10 11 and
that's where your card should live okay
so here are the first 7 8 & 9
here comes 10 11 and 12 and then the
rest of the cards so I knew your card
should be somewhere in positions 10 11
and once I've divided those cards up
I've spread them across the columns and
so now when you point to the column I
know exactly which card it is it's this
one and now to make it more exciting
instead of just saying oh here's your
card what I'm going to do is again take
a pile of seven I'm going to stick it in
front of the pile that contains your
card and then the other seven afterwards
that means 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 here's
your card it will always be in position
11 so all I need to do in this second
the last part of the trick is to count
so there's 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
there's your card so as long as I've
counted and I remember where the
card goes now I can finish out my trick
and make sure that I remove all the
groups remove all the cards that are not
the 11th card and at the very end you'll
be amazed you told me to pick groups
that's right what were you doing I was
making sure that whichever group you
picked or didn't pick it it never
removed the card that I wanted you to
find so if you said I said pick four
groups and so you pick four maybe you
pick these four I take them away you
don't tell me before if you're gonna
keep getting rid of YG's not at all
because it's because you're picking it
so you told me that you first saw this
trick as a result of learning it like
with your children that's right
did you look at it and straightaway
think mathematics or did you like how
long does it take to you start thinking
this is this is mathematical now I'd say
immediately I mean it didn't help that
the person who showed me the trick is
also a mathematician and we were with a
group of mathematicians so it's already
embedded in my brain that there's math
involved but I know that there are 21
cards
I see three piles and there are seven
cards in every pile and you're doing it
three times I knew immediately math was
involved you were youngster who does it
does she appreciate the mathematics or
has she just memorized I have to know
you know this is she loves the response
yeah she knows there's math but she's
much more excited to get the people to
just shout oh my goodness when she pulls
their card out she's just running me oh
for sure she's she's a star she's a
superstar she wants to be on TV that's
her that's her goal I think so I almost
actually almost kept one home today from
school just in case
I know what you're thinking you're
thinking gee I could really do with some
numberphile playing cards but if that's
the case check out the link in the video
description
[Music]